this is serious you are a you are a
bassoonist in uh the symphony orchestra
in in Dublin I think that's very
impressive oh well thank you yeah yeah
is it a difficult instrument do you
think it's an instrument that I could
learn to play it's not as difficult as
he probably as maybe people I don't know
maybe people don't think about the Sim
too much but it looks like a difficult
Place yeah I got really got real bad
news for you we've done a poll
we didn't even know about you but about
a week ago we did a poll on who cares
about the bassoon and the numbers are
just coming in and it's not looking good
uh no but but seriously is it I you know
I I play some music I think he
definitely could I think he definitely
could yeah what are the actions well you
play guitar so yeah what are the
attributes I have that could help me
play the bassoon well uh you need to be
a bit quirky a bit okay that's me a bit
weird around the uh yeah weirder in the
eyes sort of thing people look at you
funny
um I think I think
I check check got it what's next check
what's this yeah it just I also have
good lung power I talk constantly and I
often don't even need it I go days
without inhaling I just it's I I when I
speak it's just one long exhale for 24
hours circular breathing but for bits
instead of yes for bits and yes
yeah and you also have good lips as well
like what's good about my lips well
they're like they're they're quite
they're kind of thin and they I think
that you could be able to form like a
good embouchure around the Reed because
we use what's called a reed like like
oboists or like when if you clarinet or
saxophone would use a single read we use
a double read Greg you create a like a
good sale Greg around the did you just
Greg did you just call me thin lip
I think I'm crazy yeah so you said I
mean that'd be a good basoonist because
I'm crazy is that what you're around the
eyes wear it around the eyes yeah
can I just say Greg if if you saw if you
didn't know me but you saw me uh rob a
bank in Kildare and the police came uh
the Garda showed up and they said did
you see he goes yes I saw him would you
say he was uh weird around the eyes and
thin-lipped is that what the description
you would give to the police I say he
looks like he plays the bassoon
oh you can tell he's a known bassoonist
he's screwing through but like it's just
good for because you need a good seal
around the Reed so I if you have those
kind of those those good lips so that
air the air doesn't leak yeah I think it
could be a really good fit yeah non-lips
um that's good well uh that's good to
know I think I'd like I would take a
crack at it but I tell me
what role does the bassoon play in most
uh symphonic orchestrations where
stereotypically I'd say the jokester the
orchestras we we play lots of kind of
boom kind of notes like low notes and
with a harsh kind of Razzy sound can you
give me an example with your just
vocally can you give me an example or do
you have a bassoon with you just like oh
I do have my opinion with me actually
yeah yeah I would think you would yeah
can you give us an example on my bassoon
yeah I can do that yeah sure
um
I think like this is what we have this
is what your lips would do well with
this degrees my lips my lips are so thin
I don't even need that
I wouldn't use a reed I was very good at
like natural read
[Laughter]
okay uh so we yeah as I was saying we
have we play a lot of low notes
basically can you okay
oh
I know it's so funny Zoom doesn't like
it yeah oh no does it not no you know
what it is
but you were playing an incredibly high
note on the bassoon that we couldn't
hear that only dogs could enjoy hey son
of the amazing things in life that are
expressions of just you yeah I mean like
the chocolate that you had on your face
when you came in because you just ate
that what was it you were eating I was
eating a giant cookie giant cookie yeah
and that's so Sona okay or that song you
stream over and over again it's just so
you what's that song For You Twinkle
Twinkle Little Star yeah but it's for my
boys I know still it's nice okay or you
know that podcast that comedy podcast
you just gotta listen to yeah Conan
O'Brien needs a friend exactly is that
what you listen to in your spare time
yeah I love it everything that makes you
you makes all the difference State Farm
believes Insurance should work the same
way your plan your coverage selections
could be personalized by you and only
you that's cool I shouldn't shout but
this is how strong away I feel about it
you go to choose a plan you want by
picking the options that fit you like
choosing to bundle your home and auto
policies is what the State Farm personal
price plan is all about getting the
coverage you want at an affordable price
just for you call or go to statefarm.com
today to create your State Farm Farm
personal price plan prices vary by state
options selected by customers
availability and eligibility may vary so
um back up a little bit so we can see
this amazing instrument oh yeah
RPG yeah um I don't know what that is
okay though it doesn't even fit in the
whole video okay yeah just but we'll
have to see the whole thing but just to
get an idea there you go and I'll start
from here so um could you do us a favor
uh uh Greg I'm sure you have a bassoon
there oh there it is and
um
uh could you do us a favor and just give
us an example of the kind of things that
you would play in the orchestra you said
you play kind of
quirky jokey things give me an example
of what that would sound like
[Music]
wow I I
that's very loony too yeah yeah it
really does sound like well I'm gonna go
off to the woods now and go searching
for the Tin Man
[Music]
there's a cottage there I might go in I
just hope a witch doesn't live inside
foreign
oh no a witch does live inside
and she plays jazz on a bassoon
hey Craig wow Greg you know what
Greg I think you should immediately quit
your job
and uh you and I should take this act on
the road I improvise children's stories
and you stand next to me no I'm not
going to say we're splitting the take 50
50. that's not gonna happen right it's
gonna be a actually a split that will
appall you once you actually see it on
paper
let's hear your bassoon's reaction to
the uh
two percent yeah here's what here's the
deal I get uh of the money
oh
wow I think I just had a tracheotomy